[Music]
this world is not yet ready for all that
you will do
the time will come diana
and everything will be different
[Music]
citizens of the world i'm here to change
your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
look like you saw ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day
has passed
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now that's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules the answer
is always
more
the way i fly they will never find us i
forgot to tell you what
radar will they will they shoot at us
[Applause]
[Music]
barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i
figure uh you are but
you know what i'm ready to go i think we
can do better
parachute pants yeah um does everybody
parachute now
[Music]
[Music]
from your secret friend
[Music]
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why's he writing to you
if you are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
whoa this guy's crazy
you're part of this too
how am i part of it
you'll see
[Music]
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband fee renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
his call signs taskmaster he controls
the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
than us
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found the best
look to look into the past
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
and who you
and be my are
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's going to happen natasha
don't slouch i'm not slouching you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not
secret fair that david played
and it pleased the lord but you don't
really care for music do
it you like this the fourth
the fifth the minor fall the major lift
the battle king composing
hallelujah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i did my best it wasn't much
i couldn't feel it so i had tried to
touch
i've told the truth i'll
stand before the lord
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought in how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
welcome to ask force x these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
turn around and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you have a gift you always have
if there's an answer to your disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
i feel like more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
and an overpowering urge to consume
[Music]
blood
how far are we allowed to go
we'll fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease michael
morbiel
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing what's up doc
[Music]
5 000 years ago kondok was a melting pot
of cultures
wealth power and magic
yet most of us had nothing except for
the chains
around our necks conduct needed a hero
instead they got me i did what needed to
be done
and they imprisoned me for it
now five thousand years later
i'm free and i give you my word
no one will ever stop me again
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13 i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend i burned her
iliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it until it
kills you
who's there
we can get out of this together
[Music]
you